Hey, I'm back, Dragoons!
Sponsored by EA, and they asked me to share my story.
Thank you, EA.
I sort of want to talk about how the game changed my life.
I didn't really get into Apex until Season 2.
It was actually my very first FPS game.
I was so bad at it.
I know, it's really hard to imagine me, the FPS VTuber, being bad at the FPS game she's known for.
Like, I don't know how, but I somehow got to Predator Slash Top 500 on my first two seasons.
I know life that game so hard.
I played like 8 plus hours every day because it was just so addicting.
There's just something about the game that made it really special.
The gunplay, the movement, there's just no other game that was like this.
If it wasn't for Apex, I wouldn't be here.
I participated in worldwide tournaments, winning some of them too, played with some of the top players around the world, and created so many great memories.
I mean, I even became Gamer of the Year because of Apex.
It also led to some of my most viral moments in my career, like the snakebite question and, are you and Peter still together?
It's actually crazy.
So many people I used to watch and idolize when I was a nobody who are now my friends, know who I am, or like, even fans of me.
They're like top 10 in the world, and they're like, I'm actually a Dragoon, Doki.
And I'm like, what?
You're a Dragoon?
I'm just a little guy trying to make people laugh while pew-pewing.
But somehow, you guys just really enjoyed watching it.
So, yeah, Apex did change my life.
It led me to become the Doki you see here today.
So, thank you Apex, Respawn, and EA for creating a game that started my career.
It really is a very special game.
And that's my Apex Legends story.
What's yours?